bonjour à tous aujourd'hui petites
vidéos de vacances un format plutôt aux
cartes postales qui va être en quelque
sorte une suite de ma vidéo sur les
propriétés de l'eau aujourd'hui on va se
demander pourquoi est ce que les glaçons
refroidissent les boissons et ben parce
qu'ils ont froid merci d'avoir suivi
cette vidéo si elle vous a plu n'hésitez
pas à la partager
non je déconne en fait on va voir que la
raison pour laquelle les glaçons
refroidissent les boissons c'est pas le
fait qu'ils soient froid
une autre manière de le dire c'est qu'un
glaçon qui serait à -2 degrés il va pas
beaucoup plus refroidir un glaçon qui
serait simplement à zéro degré alors
pour comprendre ça il faut revenir sur
cette idée de refroidir quelque chose
quand on met en contact un coach aurait
encore froid il ya de la chaleur qui va
passer du corps chaud vers le corps
france et la capacité du corps froid à
absorber la chaleur en faisant monter la
température
on appelle ça la capacité calorifique
alors pour la glace la capacité
calorifique c'est à peu près 2 joules
par g et par deux grecs
c'est à dire que si on prend du tout un
glaçon de 10 grammes il va pouvoir
absorber 20 joule par degré d'élévation
de la température maxi perdants qui
passe de - 10 à 0 donc il s'élève sa
température de 10 degrés et ben au total
il aura absorbé 200 joules donc il va
reprendre 200 joules avant prêts sont
maintenant ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
que une fois qu'il a zéro degré mais le
glaçon il va pas s'arrêter là il va
fondre et le fait que le glaçon fonde sa
demande aussi de la chaleur c'est peu
pour fondre le glaçon a besoin de
prendre de la chaleur et la quantité de
chaleur qui va prendre on appelle ça la
chaleur de fusion c'est à peu près 330
joule par g
c'est à dire que pour nom de la sonde 10
grammes qui pour qu'ils puissent fondre
il va falloir qu'il prenne 3300 joule
donc si on fait le total à un glaçon qui
passent de moins 10 degrés à 0° prend
200 joules et ensuite le simple fait de
fondre
il prend 3300 joule vous voyez que la
quasi totalité du pouvoir de
refroidissement d'une glace on vient du
fait qu'ils fondent et c'est pour ça que
les glaçons qui ne fondent pas juste par
mots des glaçons en pierre on va voir un
pouvoir de refroidissement qui va être
beaucoup moins bon donc ça marchera
beaucoup moins bien sauf s'ils sont très
massif qui sont très très froid et que
vous en mettez beaucoup cette idée que
il ya un changement d'état et des
transferts de chaleur associée
en fait on la retrouve dans d'autres
situations par exemple quand vous avez
de l'eau qui est sur votre peau et qui
s'évapore parce qu'il ya du vent mais
nous avait fracassé pour la même raison
on retrouve aussi dans l'autre sens par
exemple sur les sur les chaufferettes on
trouve qu'ils peuvent qui peuvent vous
chauffez un petit moment elles sont
faites dans une substance qui est
généralement de l'acétate de sodium et
cette substance quand elle passe quand
vous déclenchez la chaufferette elle va
passer de l'état liquide à l'état solide
est en fait en faisant ça ils se passent
le phénomène inverse c'est à dire
qu'elle va libérer la chaleur si vous
voulez voir d'ailleurs comme on fait là
ses fans de sodium
je vous encourage à aller voir une vidéo
d'expérimenter bol sur le sujet donc
voilà donc la raison pour laquelle les
glaçons refroidissent les boissons ce
n'est pas le fait spécialement qu'il
soit froid c'est vraiment le fait qu'ils
fondent voilà et bien j'espère que vous
regarderez vous aux glaçons et vos
boissons d'un autre oeil cet été merci à
bientôt